all right
today we're going to look at the
reaction of magnesium with nitrogen in
the air and this is an experiment which
in one of our videos I said I had tried
for 25 years in front of the students
and it had never worked out of the blue
I got an email from a viewer called
Karsten in Germany
who said he had the book of experiments
in German and
he told us how to do it the difference
is that this experiment uses magnesium
granules and I was using magnesium
ribbon the experiment consists of making
a little pyramid of magnesium granules
setting fire to them in air so it begins
to burn making magnesium oxide
and then taking a big beaker
and putting it upside down over the
Magnesium which is already burning
and of course because the beaker
contains air it continues to burn making
magnesium oxide but it uses up the
oxygen inside the beaker so that the
beaker just contains nitrogen
as the Magnesium is already very hot it
starts burning in nitrogen or reacting
with nitrogen
it's quite slow I thought the reaction
wasn't going to happen and then spark
starts coming from this little pyramid
and then it starts glowing brighter and
brighter and a plume comes out like an
erupting volcano and it reacts until
most of the nitrogen is used up and as
it starts reacting with the nitrogen you
get a blue green color in the flame I'm
not sure what that is it might be from
nitrogen atoms recombining which give a
green color but the reaction eventually
finishes
Neil got a big glove and removed the
beaker it was very hot the pyramid was
white on the outside with magnesium
oxide but when he cut it in half with a
spatula inside it was Sun black from the
unreacted Magnesium but yellow color
which is magnesium nitride mg3 N2 but
then comes the really exciting part you
can react the magnesium nitride with
water and it forms ammonia which as you
know is a gas and it is alkaline if it
touches something that is wet so Neil
tried some indicator paper that goes a
sort of bluish color when you have an
Alkali and phenolphthalein paper which
starts weight and goes blood red and
they both worked
the second time it worked better
Neil was considerably more satisfied and
we got a bigger plume and the magnesium
nitride was definitely more Apparent at
the end
we did the water and got the colors it's
quite interesting that if you look under
the thermal camera the indicator papers
actually warm up when the ammonia or the
hot Vapors touch it
so the interesting question is why did
my experiment never work and karsten's
experiments succeed my experiment
consisted of taking a piece of magnesium
ribbon lighting it in there and then
plunging it into a container filled with
nitrogen gas it just went out I think
the difference was that my magnesium
ribbon wasn't nearly as hot as the
massive magnesium granules that Neil was
using this is a reaction which has high
activation energy you need to put in a
lot of heat to get it going and I just
didn't have the thing hot enough there's
the other chemical question
why does magnesium ever react with
nitrogen because N2 gas has the
strongest bond that is known between two
atoms that are the same the NN bond is
very strong to break that bond is why
the reaction needs so much heat to get
going but in a chemical reaction for it
to work you may have to put heat in but
you need to get more heat out to make
the whole process go and what happens in
this case
is that you form magnesium two plus ions
a nitride three minus ions both of which
are quite small and which have a high
charge plus two minus three and the
energy when these come together positive
and negative attract and when they come
together in a lattice you get a lot of
energy back and the closer the ions come
together the greater the energy so
having small ions with a high charge
gives you a lot of energy back the
problem with the demonstration we've
done
was that you don't see whether the
oxygen has been used up in the air it
could just be burning so I persuaded
Neil to do a third experiment in a
bigger beaker
but the beaker was big enough that we
could also have a candle burning under
the beaker so now we could use the
candle like a canary used to be used
down coal mines to see when the air was
running out and if you watch you can see
they both start burning both the candle
and the magnesium and as the process
goes on the candle starts getting
smaller and smaller and goes out but the
Magnesium keeps going takes a bit of
time to get going and then the plume of
the volcano reappears and at the end we
got really quite a nice amount of
magnesium nitride this yellow solid and
the amount of ammonia was
impressive the heat of the reaction
melted one side of the candle which was
quite satisfying but Neil who often is
cleverer than me pointed out that this
experiment was not perfect because when
the candle burnt It produced carbon
dioxide and water vapor which
accumulates inside the beaker so we were
actually changing the chemistry or
potentially as well now the one question
that we haven't answered is why did the
beaker fill with white smoke and I think
the answer to that is that the white
smoke is actually very finely divided
magnesium oxide and you see the same
white smoke when you let off fireworks
which often contain magnesium and they
produce magnesium oxide
but overall it was a very satisfying
experiment and I thank you Karsten
for putting us onto it
[Music]
have a look at the link in the video
description to find out about becoming a
patreon supporter and getting your name
on our Periodic Table of patrons like
these people here
I'll also put a link in the video
description to recent news about our
very own senior technician Neil Barnes
who's won a very impressive honor from
the Royal Society make sure you have a
click on that
[Music]